>>presenter: Good afternoon, everyone. It's
a nice, sunny day. It's a actually Bloomsday
for the James Joyce fans among us, and it's
also the day for another outstanding green
and Google Talk. So, it is my great pleasure
to introduce Jeff Goodell. Three of the five
main arms of the google.org deal with sustainability
issues and finding renewable resources and
renewable energy that costs less than coal-powered,
for example. And so, we're always very keen
on new ideas on, in the sustainability and
the environmental front. And Jeff brings us
today a particularly compelling story, in
this case, on geoengineering and its effects
and its potential solutions for the global
warming issues. So, Jeff is a contributing
editor to Rolling Stone and he's an author
of a variety of books. And his most recent
book before this one was entitled "Big Coal"
and was a very compelling argument about the
state of emerging technologies to be cheaper
than coal energy. Using a frank tone and scientific
evidence, he helps us navigate the complex
environmental issues of our day, whether it's
through his books or through his columns in
the Rolling Stone. Now, Jeff is fresh off
a trip to the Arctic Circle--pertinent to
our talk today--so, the relationship there
is quite apropos. He'll be speaking to us
on his current book, which is entitled "How
to Cool the Planet: Geoengineering and the
Audacious Quest to Fix Earth's Climate." In
it, he discusses the state-of-the-art and
the emerging technologies on the geoengineering
front and its potential for a long term climate
solution. We'll have time for some Q and A
at the end, so please use the Q and A mic.
And without further ado, please join me in
welcoming Jeff to Google.
[applause]
>>Jeff: Thank you very much, Cliff. Am I all
right here? Yes, I am just back from the Arctic
and at the end of the talk, I'll tell you
about my polar bear encounters. I just did
a two hundred mile cross-country ski trip
on Baffin Island across from Greenland, which
was quite wild and interesting, but not the
subject of the talk today. I want to talk
about this book, "How to Cool the Planet",
and this idea of geoengineering. And I think
that it's important to first make clear what
geoengineering is, since most people have
never heard of it. And geoengineering is--I
would argue-- going to be something, it's
going to be for the 21st Century, something
like nuclear weapons were for the 20th Century,
a big, disruptive idea that might, is likely
to change the way we think about our place
in the natural world and our relationship
with technology. And geoengineering, I think,
is most simply defined as large-scale intervention
with the climate system in order to offset,
or reduce the risk of global warming. There
are a couple ways to do that, which I'll talk
about in some detail, but the two basic ways
are to use technologies to block some sunlight
from hitting the planet and cool things off
in a very direct way, in the same way that
a parasol blocks sunlight. If you open a parasol,
it'll be to you even cooler, essentially throwing
some shade on the planet. And the other category
of geoengineering is technologies that can
suck CO2 out of the atmosphere directly. So,
there's two broad kind of categories of this
and I'll go into this, into some of the details
shortly. Though I think it's very important
to make very clear from the beginning that
this is not a simple solution, a simple quick
fix for global warming. This is not a substitute
for cutting emissions. This is a techno fix.
It is a band-aid. It is chemotherapy. It is
all of these kinds of complicated technological
solutions for things that we should cure in
a more straightforward way, which is by cutting
emissions. That's how we deal with global
warming, by reducing the amount of CO2 that
we dump into the atmosphere. However, there's
a problem, which is, after 30 years of talking
about cutting emissions, we're still not doing
anything about it. Emissions are going up
more or less as rapidly as they've ever been
going up. I'm sure you all know about the
problems with getting agreements on international
emissions reductions at Copenhagen and other
places and other international meetings. We
have not come to any agreement; we're really
not doing anything meaningful about this,
despite all the talk, despite all the investment
in green technology. The thing that really
matters, which is the amount of CO2 that's
going into the atmosphere is still globally
increasing more or less as rapidly as it ever
has. So, the question becomes-- so in a certain
way, geoengineering is a technical fix for
a political problem; sort of how I've come
to see it. And the question that this raises
is, is there a new way to think about this?
Is there something to be gained by thinking
about dealing with the risk of global warming
in a different way than we have? And what
are those risks and what are the consequences
of thinking about something as sort ofobviously
crazy and radical as trying to mess with the
Earth's climate in a very deliberate way?
So, I thought the best way for me to talk
about this book and why I did it, is to tell
you a little bit about myself and my background
and why I did this; wrote on what seems to
anyone who thinks about this for two seconds,
a bold, reckless and probably crazy idea.
And I think it's important to tell you about
where I came from and one of the places I
came from is like, right down the road. I
grew up here in Sunnyvale. This is a picture
of me at the Santa Cruz Boardwalk at age seven
or something. I lived here; I worked at Apple
in the very early days. I went to Berkeley.
And I grew up with this idea of technology
being able to fix complicated problems. It
was sort of something that someone like myself
who grew up around here, you come to really
believe in and really think about. And they
sort of, I often joke that they sort of put
it in the water, like fluoride around here,
this kind of optimism about what technology
can do. And I proved a very little talent
for coding or any kind of engineering that
would, kept me around here. I decided I wanted
to go off and do other things and be a writer.
But in the '80s and '90s, I was drawn back
to Silicon Valley and did a lot of writing
for Rolling Stone and for New York Times Magazine
and other publications about the Internet
boom, about Netscape, about the early days
of the Internet, what turned out to be the
Internet bubble and I was a big booster and
a big believer and I always have been in the
power of digital technology to transform our
lives to help us think in new, creative ways
about various problems, about the social networking
and all this stuff. The one thing I never
thought about at all was-- I mean, I obviously
knew that this economy is built on electrons--
but I never thought about where those electrons
come from. If you grew up in California, you
don't see coal plants, you don't see, I remember
seeing the wind turbines at Altamont Pass
and we would drive by. Sometimes, we would
go out to Lake Shasta and see the dam there,
but I never really connected any of that to
this digital revolution that was happening
in the valley. I never gave any thought to
what the real consequences of these electrons,
of this electron economy really is. And then,
in 2001, I was sitting at my desk in New York
and an editor at the New York Times Magazine
called me and asked me if I wanted to write
about the comeback of the coal industry, because
that had been around the time the Bush-Cheney
energy plan had been rolled out and it was
clear that there was gonna be a lot more fossil
fuels burned in America. And I hesitated and
little thought bubble above my head said,
"What coal industry?" I'd never seen coal
in my life before. I had no idea, in fact,
that we even still used it. And I imagined
it was something that would comes out of Charles
Dickens's novels and things like that. I was
completely naive. I, of course, said-- I didn't
tell that to my editor-- I said, "Great."
And I went to West Virginia and I got my first
look at coal. And I discovered very quickly
that half the electricity in America comes
from coal; that coal is really central to
keeping our economy going. And it was really
an eye-opening little trip for me. I, this
is a picture of a mountaintop removal mine.
This is myself talking with an activist there
and it really, if I remember the first time
that I saw a mountaintop removal mine, I drove
out of Charleston and saw a big dragline;
it's like a bit shovel that they use in coal
mines to haul dirt around over the top of
the mountain. And I climbed up this mountain
and looked down into a mine like this, and
this is, this photograph is a very small piece
of it, but they're these enormous mines; thousands
of acres huge. And it was really a stunning
experience for me because all of a sudden
I realized that these mountains were being
blown up. I saw the economic devastation,
I saw the environmental devastation in the
coal fields and I realized that this was the
underbelly of the digital economy. This is,
what we're doing here, what you're doing here
at Google, is powered by this and there's
a direct connection between those two. And
I had never thought about that way. I never
thought of myself as implicit in this whole
thing and yet, clearly, I was. And so I spent
a few months working on a big story that became
a cover story for The New York Times Magazine
about the coal industry. I learned about the
consequences of burning coal, not just the
destruction of the mountains in West Virginia
and Appalachia, but also air pollution issues
and most importantly, of course, global warming
because coal is the most carbon intensive
fossil fuel and it is basically the reason
that we're heating up the planet so quickly,
is that not only the United States, but also
developing nations, like China and India are
burning a lot of coal. It's cheap, it's easy
to get out of the ground, we know what to
do with it and it is a big, big problem. So,
I spent, I decided that I had not really gone
deeply enough into coal. I spent the next
three years writing a book about the coal
industry and looking at the problems, but
also what might be done. Is, are we gonna
develop solar power, wind power, alternatives,
renewable energies quickly enough to displace
coal? How are we going to do that? What is
the sort of options with that? What are the
possibilities of capturing carbon dioxide
from coal plants, burying it, dealing, burning
coal in a way that makes it a suitable fuel
for the 21st Century? And basically, I came
to the conclusion that we're just gonna keep
burning coal the same old way for a very long
time and we're basically going to cook the
planet with it. That, when you looked at the
large trends in developing nations and in
the US, the political problems of displacing
the coal industry, very, very many reasons
that we were not gonna come anywhere near
reducing emissions to these levels that climate
scientists were telling us we needed to do,
right? You all know about targets that are
being, that the IPCC--the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change-- have set; that President
Obama talks about talks about that we need
to cut emissions by 80%by 2050, there's various
numbers out there to avert the risk of serious
climate change. And what I figured out from
my years with the coal industry was that we're
not gonna come anywhere near those targets.
There's no way we're gonna, we're gonna, we're
going to meet those targets. And I finished
the book in 2006, in the four years since;
it's just been proven more true. We are just
not getting up the political moxey to really
do anything about this. Even President Obama,
who we all, who were involved in energy and
climate issues had great hopes that he would
really do something bold in the first term
on climate and energy, has really not done
much except talk really a lot about it. But
he hasn't really put his shoulder to the wheel
in any meaningful way. So, what I began to
think about was, "What are we going to do?"
This is just a, I'm just gonna show you a
couple of charts that hit me at that time,
which are the--and I promise not to give you,
show you very many charts at all because I
know how boring they are-- but this is just
shows you the red line is the worst case scenario
emissions that the IPCC projected. And you
can see that from the 2005-2006, were already
way above that. So, we're emitting CO2 more
at a higher rate than we, that even the worst
case scenarios that we anticipated a few years
ago. And one of the important things about
this is that-- and I came to understand as
I was looking into this question of what are
we going to do-- is that I think most people
don't get that CO2 is not like local air pollution.
When I grew up here, in Silicon Valley, I
remember how polluted the air was when I was
a kid; it was really bad. And then there was
various laws passed, catalytic converters,
various things happened and the air got a
lot better. You clean up the tailpipes of
cars, pollution falls out of the sky, you
breathe better, it goes away, it's all good.
CO2 greenhouse gases are not like that. CO2
remains in the atmosphere a large percentage
of it for thousands of years. It doesn't go
away when you stop turning off emissions.
If you stop burning coal, it doesn't go away
immediately. Plus, there's a lot of heat built
up in the ocean. The ocean acts like a giant
fly, we all absorbing heat and it's going
to continue radiating for a long time. So,
one fundamental fact that I did not know,
and I think a lot of people who think about
the issue of energy and climate stuff still
don't quite grasp, is that even if we cut--
if we all went to skateboards tomorrow and
there was no vehicles, we cut emissions to
zero tomorrow, this planet is still gonna
keep warming up for the rest, most of the
rest of this century. So, if we have to cool
things off, if for some reason we decided
we needed to actually lower temperature, like
Greenland is starting to melt in a very dramatic
way, what would we do? It's not gonna be enough
to say "no more"--not that this has ever happened,
of course, anyway-- but it won't be enough
to say "no more coal, no more oil, no more
fossil fuels." We're already locked in for
long-term warming. So, I came to think about
this thing called, I started hearing about
this idea of geoengineering. It was, I first
heard about it in a talk, in a paper that
I read from a very, from a Nobel Laureate
atmospheric scientist named Paul Crutzen,
who published a paper about this idea of putting
particles up into the stratosphere. Basically,
the idea, he already agreed that we would
be getting into dangerous situation with climate
change. How would we, what would we do if
we had to cool things off quickly? And he
came up with this idea of--it's not his idea--but
he wrote about this notion that we could put
little particles of sulfur high up in the
stratosphere, 60,000feet or so, would act
like tiny mirrors, essentially doing what
volcanoes do. We know from history the volcanoes
cool off the planet. Mount Pinatubo which
erupted in the Philippines in 1991 lowered
the temperature of the Earth for about a degree
for a few years. We know that this works.
You put the particles up high in the stratosphere,
they reflect sunlight like little mirrors,
the sunlight cools things down and the reduction
of the sunlight cools things down, and you
don't have to reduce a whole lot to have a
meaningful impact. The common measurement
for climate sensitivity is to think about
doubling of CO2 emissions and what would that
do to the raising of the temperature of things.
Well, to offset the warming of the doubling
of CO2 emissions, you only have to produce
one or two percent of the sunlight, so it's
just a little bit and it could have a big
impact. So, around two, three years ago, people
started thinking about this and people saying,
"Well, we're not reducing emissions. Is this
a possible solution? Is this one way that
we might be able to at least buy ourselves
more time?" And I, like others, started thinking
about this. And this led me to a man named
Lowell Wood, here in the Valley. Actually,
he was in Livermore at the time. And Lowell
Wood is a very well-known astrophysicist.
He was Edward Teller's right hand man. He's
one, one partly responsible for the construction
of Star Wars Missile Defense System, the big
boondoggle that cost billions of dollars and
never quite got launched or worked in any
way, but was big part of the Reagan era defense
things. And I started hearing Lowell's name
and I decided to look him up and going to
see Lowell was like looking into the mountaintop
removal mine; a kind of transformative experience
for me because he is so brilliant and so crazy.
And you don't meet many people like that in
the world, maybe you do, but I don't meet
so many people who-- and he was brilliant
and crazy in the best kinds of ways. And he
really challenged my thinking about a lot
of this and his basic view is, "Look, the
physics of this work, we know how to do this.
We're not gonna cut emissions; get used to
it. Welcome to the world of geoengineering.
This is where we are going as human civilization.
This is our future." Cause he was very cynical
about the way politics works. He was very
cynical that we'd ever--any politician-- would
ever make a hard decision like saying, "Let's
put a cap on carbon." Something like that
that actually cost people money or seems to
cost people money. And so, and Lowell had
done some work on this idea of putting particles
up in the stratosphere and one of the things
that was really interesting that he had done
in, that with some modeling with a scientist
named Ken Caldeira at Stanford, is that if
you put enough particles in the stratosphere
to cool the planet by a few degrees, you can
reduce the-- well, let me put this in a different
way. Some of the climate modeling shows that
if you look at impacts of doublingof CO2,
and then you try to, and then you do the same
kind of climate modeling with sulfur particles
in the stratosphere, the amount of the geoengineered
world with the particles in the stratosphere
is more like where we're living now than it
will with doubled CO2. So, that's a very interesting,
provocative idea that maybe we can modulate
the sunlight a little bit and maybe we can
preserve the climate or cool things down or
reduce the risk of change by doing some of
these radical interventions, innovations.
Now, Lowell had some crazy ideas about how
you did this and one of his ideas was to put
a Kevlar tube in the Arctic or somewhere,
or near the equator; various ideas about where
and how to do this. But basically, a Kevlar
tube, it would pump these particles up into
the stratosphere at 60,000 feet, a tube that
was hung from a high-altitude balloon. He
also explored the ideas of using high-altitude
aircraft, not unlike the one that's hanging
in the lobby here as I walked in. They're
all, it's all ready to go here. The geoengineering's
all ready to go. A various, even some scientists
before have even talked about using artillery
shells to put it up there. But, the upshot
of all this was, to me, was that, and Lowell
was, when I asked him, "Well, Lowell, you're
messing with the climate system. What is this
gonna do to rainfall? What is this going to
do to possibility of droughts? What is this,
how is this going to, what impact is this
going to have on the oceans?" And Lowell's
like, "Oh well, we'll work that out. That's
not a big problem. We'll figure this out.
The point is we know how to do this." And
so, his brashness really opened my eyes and
challenged me. So, I wrote a Rolling Stone's
story about him and this is just an example
of the volcano and how they work. This is
from the recent on in Iceland, which was not
big enough to really have a big impact and
didn't put the aerosols high enough to have
a large impact. But one of the key things
that Lowell points out, and the scientists
who look at this point out, is that there's
a lot of leverage in doing this. All you have
to do is put five grams of sulfur in the stratosphere
and it basically offsets the warming of a
ton of carbon. So, you can see why the physics,
the dynamics of this are very appealing and
very interesting. You don't have to put much
stuff up there in order to cool things down.
Now, this got me going to thinking about other
ideas and I came across this guy named John
Latham, who's a cloud physicist. He's, spends
his part of his time in England; part of his
time in the US. And he had been looking at
ship tracks. Now, this is a satellite photo
of the Atlantic and those little lines you
see are tracks where ships went. And what
happens is when the ships go in this region
of the Atlantic, the small particles from
the diesel fuel go up into the low level cloud
area there and create, essentially, create
clouds in certain regions. So, these, these
particles act as cloud condensation nuclei,
basically giving the droplets, the vapor in
the air a place to condense and create low
level clouds. And these kinds of clouds; clouds
are very complicated in this sort of climate
dynamics, but these kinds of clouds in this
region reflect away sunlight. So, you had
to have the, a similar affect to the stratosphere
particles, except that they are clouds. Now
John got the idea that maybe we could do this
deliberately. Why not do this deliberately?
And he, along with an engineer, a quite brilliant
engineer in Scotland, came up with these idea
for these boats that use, that actually spray
salt water up into these areas where these
marine strata cumulus clouds can be brightened
and use the actual salt crystals in the salt
water as condensation nuclei. And they're
a lot of modeling has shown that this can
be very, very, have a very, very powerful
impact on cooling off the planet in a similar
way, although not quite as globally, as particles.
So, I got interested in that. But I think
the most interesting scientist that I met
that really is the guy who got me to write
this book and who I actually just went to
the Arctic with--that's a picture of us, or
him in the Arctic just a few weeks ago-- is
a guy named David Keith, an engineer at the
University, a physicist at the University
of Calgary, Canada. And David is a really
brilliant guy, who's been thinking about geoengineering
as long as anybody and he had a lot of ideas
about how you would put particles in the stratosphere,
how these cloud brightening things might work;
he was also interesting in building machines
that could suck CO2 out of the atmosphere.
And one of the things that happened with me
and David is that he's about as hardcore and
a kind of environmentalist as anyone I know.
And is very deeply connected to the Arctic
and to the North. And basically, made this
argument to me that if, that geoengineering
can be a kind of conservation tool; that if
you really care about, say, the Arctic ecosystem,
given the kind of front loading of heat and
warming that we already have, exploring geoengineering
is basically the, one of the only ways we
have to possibly preserve this ecosystem;
to cool things down. Cause otherwise, it's
more or less a goner this century. The Arctic
would, as we know it today, will not exist.
And so, if you wanna think about how to, how
might we preserve that, then you have to start
thinking about geoengineering. A day that
is, I was really moved by his connection with
this place. This is a polar bear we encountered
while we were up there. But it gave me a seed
that this tool, like many tools, it seems
scary at first, can be used in a variety of
ways that are not necessarily the sort of
the evil technologist taking over the planet;
that they might be used for preservation,
for traditional environmental purposes. And
this is just some climate modeling that shows
where the red is; actually, at the bottom
is the Arctic on the right. And that just
shows how you can actually grow back the ice
in the Arctic by seeding, in this case, 70%
of the cloud area of the oceans. You can actually
begin to grow back some of the ice in the
Arctic, not a lot of preserving, but you actually,
you can see what's happening, right? It's
about building a global thermostat; it's about
building tools to modulate the Earth's climate
to actually begin to dial it in and to say,
"Ok, what temperature do we want? Where do
we want this to be?" Now, this is a recent
rendering of a big air capturing machine that
David Keith is working on. He's been funded
by Bill Gates, and others to explore this
idea of building machine that can actually
suck CO2 out of the atmosphere and this is
a model rendering of one of these, what these,
one of these machines might look like. It's
very doable. It uses very straightforward
chemical processes. The problem with it is
that it's very expensive compared to traditional
ways of like getting CO2 from coal plants
or something. But, out of coal plant stacks.
But, it is obviously something that just beginning
to be developed. I like to think of it as
an iron lung for the planet that could eventually
be-- the good thing about these things is
that you could put them anywhere. You can
put them in the desert, in wasted spaces,
pull the CO2 out, you could bury it underground,
you could do various things to it; use it
for industrial purposes and it gives us a
way to disconnect the removal of CO2 from
energy sources. So, this is really important
to think about because this is, of course,
the big, the big issue, which is when you
start messing with something like the climate
system, what might go wrong? And one of the
really important things to say is that reducing
sunlight is not the same as cutting CO2. The
CO2 is, causes many other problems and among
them, most seriously, acidification of the
oceans, which is a very big deal and is having
a devastating impact on the food chain. So,
if you just throw up sulfur particles in the
stratosphere and reduce the heat of the planet,
you're still allowing high levels of CO2,
which cause acidification of the oceans. So,
that is a potentially devastating side effect.
Shifting precipitation patterns around, a
lot of some modeling has shown that putting
particles in the stratosphere will have an
impact on the rainfall in the Amazon and in
some of the monsoons and that you begin to
shift rainfall patterns around, you begin
to shift agricultural food growing patterns
around; could have huge impact on millions
of people, obviously. But the key thing to
think about with this is that it's not like
we're, this is a virgin planet, we're already
going to be shifting around precipitation
patterns, rainfall, by continuing to dump
CO2 into the atmosphere. So, it's not like
with this going to happen anyway. It may happen
in a different way and we can begin to think
about how this might be controlled, but it's
not like building condos in a virgin Redwood
forest. There's a whole issue of this is a,
just a suggestion, of nuclear war-- of nuclear,
the parallels with nuclear power and nuclear
war and nuclear testing. The problem with
geoengineering is that it, is it inverses
the problem that we have right now with global
warming and getting emissions reduced, which
is a collective action problem. Geoengineering
is a lone actor problem, sort of like nuclear
war in that you can have an individual nation,
a collection of nations, even a well intentioned
individual could potentially put particles
in the stratosphere, get a few airplanes like
the one in your lobby, again. Start throwing
particles up there. Well intentioned, perhaps,
maybe tired of the fact that, of our Western
civilization diddling and not doing anything
and saying, Okay. "Hell with it. I want to
experiment with this and try this." So, the
question is, what do you do if you have an
individual or a nation; China, India, collection
of smaller developing nations, who come together
and decide to do this? How do you react? What
kind of governance structure do you need to
restrain people? How would you, would it be
to trigger a war? What would it do? Because
this stuff is not that complicated and not
that expensive in the big picture to actually
do. And the other big question is who eats
the risk? Which is, when you start playing
with this, right? When you start playing with
the climate system there's going to be winners
and losers, just as there's going to be winners
and losers as we continue to warm things up
by dumping CO2 into the atmosphere. But what's
happening now is we're doing it unintentionally,
supposedly. Now, of course, it's intentional,
but for most part, this is an unintentional
messing with the system. When we start, if
we start doing geoengineering, then we start
actually saying, "Ok, we're going to cool
things to this level. We're going to try altering
things in this way." And then there are going
to be winners and losers from that. There's
going to be people whose rainfall patterns
change or even think they change. And how
do you deal with that? This is, this question
though, of who eats the risk is something
that's in the news even right now with the
oil spill, right? Here we had this whole question
of, where was the backup plan for what happened
in the Gulf, right? And you could ask a similar
question with climate engineering, which is
you can think of climate engineering as a
sort of backup plan if we get into a real
bad climate equivalent of a meltdown. What
might we do? And geoengineering is one thing
that we might do that could help mitigate
some of the risk to the rest of us. But it's
clear that if we do any kind of geoengineering,
this is not gonna be done by poor farmers
in Africa, right? This is gonna be done by
rich, technologically sophisticated nations
whether they're US, Western civilization as
we know, or, like I said, developing nations,
but it's going to be people who have airplanes
and climate models and things like that. And
so, how do you give people a voice in this
when you're messing with essentially the operating
systems for the entire planet? How do you
make this, in any sense, fair or democratic?
And these are governance issues that are just
beginning to be discussed now, even talked,
to be talked about seriously. So, let me wrap
this up by asking rhetorically this key question,
which is, is geoengineering just a bad sci-fi
novel writ large? Which is what it seems like
to most people who look at it and think about
it. And I think it's easy to argue that it
is. I think that's it's easy to argue this
is a very bad idea. It's easy to argue that
no sane person would ever voluntarily want
to do this and that the fact that we're even
talking seriously about it is an indication
of how screwed up our whole climate and energy
debate is right now. And you can certainly
argue that we, as human beings, have done
a bad job at managing the planet already.
So, that it now, so now we're gonna be more
actively managing it, we're gonna try even
harder to get our fingers in the things where
we've already screwed things up enormously.
I mean, this, just this photo for me just
is a symbol of the sort of artifice of mindless
expansion and mindless human development.
But one of the things that interesting about
geoengineering, I think, is that I came to
the conclusion that it doesn't have to be
that way. That this, that there's an argument
to be made for mindful and more artful manipulation
of nature, to put it bluntly. And that consciousness
is doing, what we've been doing now is just
dumping billions of tons of CO2 into the atmosphere
with no thought, essentially, about what the
real consequences would be. What happens if
we begin to understand how we might pull the
levers and the pulleys of the climate system
a little bit better? And one of the inspirations
for me and thinking differently about this
was and this is my daughter, Grace, who's
seven, who is a big gardener. Those are pumpkins
that she grew. And one of the things that
happens in our family, in our house, is that
we, my wife is a big gardener, my daughter's
a big gardener and this idea of a garden is
a very powerful metaphor, I think, for thinking
about how, what we might do with the climate--with
the planet and for what our responsibilities
are. Because a garden is a very powerful evidence
of this beauty of working with nature, of
human and natural partnerships together. These
pumpkins would not have grown this way, the
whole, on their own if a product of my wife
and my daughter's care and attention and that
a well-tended garden is a beautiful thing
and that this could be extended as a metaphor
for how we think about our relationship with
the planet. Can we become better engineers?
Can we become better gardeners? Because I
think, to wrap this up, I wanna say just two
things. One is that my conclusion at the end
of this was that we are going to geoengineer
the planet; that Lowell was right. This is
our future, but if we admit it or not, this
is gonna happen because we are just not dealing
with this problem in any other way. But even
more broadly, that this is something that
we, as human beings, do. We mess with the
world we live in and we try to control the
world that we live in. We control the buildings
we live in, we control the temperature here;
we're getting to a point where we're going
to have to learn how to control the climate
because otherwise, we're not gonna survive,
broadly speaking. Not you and I, I think that,
I'm not saying that human beings are going
to vanish, but in general, the idea of modern
civilization as we know it is not going to
survive without us taking more active management
in the climate system. And to me, that is
the best thing about this geoengineering debate,
which I've gotten a lot of heat about from
my environmentalist friends for bringing this
up. There's a lot of questions about will
this, the idea of this diet pill for the planet,
as some people have talked about it, cut the
political impulse to reduce emissions, to
take away from the energy. People think that
there's a simple way out and nobody wants
to run five miles if they can just take a
pill and be skinny. Americans have shown that
over and over, right? So, is this a easy way
out? A dangerous way out? And certainly done
badly, it certainly is. But I think that for
me, having a conversation about this, of letting,
of getting this sort of genie out of the box,
talking openly about the possibility-- not
just the possibility, the reality that this
can be done, that the physics are straightforward,
the costs are relatively inexpensive and there's
a lot of political will behind this idea.
I think it's really important because it makes
clear this, what to me, is the central point
in all this climate stuff of which is that
we humans are in control. And just to have
a conversation about geoengineering, you have
to talk about, "OK, what kind of planet do
we want to live on?" Do we want to live on
a planet where we don't mess with the clouds
and we don't mess with the stratosphere because
we are, we think it's too dangerous and so
we're going to let warming go? Do we wanna
live on a planet where we are going to cut
emissions? I think that this making explicit
that it's not nature that's in control anymore;
it is us that is in control of the kind of
world we live in is really key and central.
And you can't talk about geoengineering without
acknowledging that. And that winds up to the
last final exact, last final point, which
is that after we, spending three years talking
to scientists about this--environmentalists
and everything-- what really scares me is
not technological hubris. That's what a lot
of people talk about when they talk about
geoengineering technological hubris. What
scares me is human apathy. And I think the
degree that this discussion about geoengineering
wakes people up, makes us realize how, what
kind of situation we're in, makes us at least
make some decisions about how much control
we wanna exert over this world we live in
is one of the most important points of this
whole topic. And with that, I'm happy to take
any questions and thank you very much.
[applause]
>>Cliff: All right, so, with any luck, we've
got the Q and A mic right here if you have
any questions. I want to kick it off with
just one quick one here in, the debate on
geoengineering is reallyintriguing and I like
a lot of the ideas that you presented. How
do we prevent this from becoming like introducing
the cane toad to Australia, that we're gonna
need like another, another fix or a point
of no return where we're like committed to
like this track or another track?
>>Jeff: Well, that's a great point. A lot
of people bring up the cane toad analogy.
So, obviously have a bad track record of trying
to intervene in a helpful way with, to solve
problems like this, but one of the virtues
of some of these systems is especially the
two that I talked about most, which are cloud
brightening and the sulfur particles, is that
they are reversible. Right? You put these
particles in the stratosphere and they are
gone in a year; they fall out. So, an ideal,
rational world, you start with a little bit
of it, you put a little bit up there, you
see what happens. If they, if there's any
problems, it, you stop and it falls out and
more or less goes back to where it was a year
later. Same thing with cloud brightening.
These cloud brightening ideas, you try brightening
a few clouds, you see what happens; it doesn't
work, you don't like the way it works, it's
changing something you don't understand, blah
blah blah, you turn it off and it stops. So,
there's an element of reversibility to any
of these technologies that, I would say, should
be at least explored to see what the real
risks are. So, that is a big issue and the
problem with the cane toad thing is that is
wasn't reversible. You let a few of them out
and all of a sudden you've got a big, big
problem. And I think that we've learned a
lot from this kind of thing. And humbleness
is a key virtue in this whole notion that
is a obviously, a hubristic idea. And so I
think that there are ways of doing it that
really reduce those kinds of risks.
>>male #1: You talked a lot about the risks
which people see in it, which makes sense,
and you also said, which I think is accurate,
that Lowell Wood observed that politicians
are unable to stop what's happening now, so
how can politicians make the decision to take
these risks that everybody sees to pursue
some sort of geoengineering?
>>Jeff: Well, that's a good question. I mean,
I think that there's two parts of that, that
one is the near term question is how do you
allow politicians-- how do we get some kind
of sub-scale testing going on? Because what
really has to happen is these, a lot of these
ideas, we know work because of the natural
analogs, like volcanoes and ship tracks and
things like that, but we haven't really done
them yet, right? That we've done climate modeling
and things like that, but there's no real
experiments going on. And to understand what
the risks are, we need to do some of those
experiments. So we know, maybe this is a terrible,
terrible idea for reasons that we have not
understood yet and so we should absolutely
take it off the menu. But that requires some
political courage to say we need to do this,
right? We need to acknowledge, I mean, the
basic problem is that don't even acknowledge
that global warming is a serious problem we
need to deal with on any level, right? We're
like, that's why I showed the BP thing. It's
like, how do we plan, how did BP plan for
an emergency response? It was to not have
an emergency, right? And that's how we're
planning with climate is like our emergency
response for climate is to not have an emergency.
But, of course, that's just putting our head
in the sand and we know every scientist has
been telling us for the last 20 years that
the risks that we're running as CO2 levels
get higher and higher and higher. And so,
one of the big fears is that this, we will
not do any research on geoengineering. We'll
not do any serious thinking about geoengineering
and we'll not be doing any serious reductions
of emissions and we'll have some kind of a
climate--maybe catastrophe is too much of
a word-- but a kind of climate equivalent
of the subprime mortgage meltdown, or the
BP thing. And politicians will then wanna
say, "Do something." But they need to take
action, right? Just like we needed to bomb
Iraq after 9/11. We need, we need action.
It's like Obama right now with BP; he's gotta
show that he's in charge, right? He's gotta
show his muscle right now and there's this
fight going on. And one of the big fears that
a lot of people, serious scientists who look
at geoengineering, I think is that if push
comes to shove and we do have to take action,
some of these ideas will be what we will do
because they can cool things off quickly.
And if we don't know more about the pluses
and minuses, the real risks, then we're going
to be doing this blindly and that's when it's
really risky and really a problem. Does that
help?
>>member #2: What are the health impacts of
pumping up sulfur?
>>Jeff: I'm sorry, what are the what?
>>male #2: What are the health impacts of
pumping up sulfur in the atmosphere? Isn't
that similar to like, particle pollution?
>>Jeff: That's a question that everyone that
asks, that makes total sense and that I am
asked a lot and even the--and there are many
people who think that putting particles in
the stratosphere is a crazy idea-- even those
most outspoken critics don't see any health
impact problems because the amount that you
have to put up there is so small compared
to what's already up there. It's basically
not noticeable, and it doesn't contribute
to acid rain. It, it's really, and there are
other issues such as the health issues, such
as what impact these particles might have
on atmospheric chemistry and the ozone hole;
to what degree they might contribute to the,
or slow the healing of the ozone hole, things
like that which could have health impacts.
But as far as particles breathing in the way
that we do with coal plants and things like
that, not really an issue. Because I remember
coal plants puts stuff up very low level,
basically here in the air that we breathe.
This would be high, very high up, very dispersed
and it would just basically be in the mix
in, of real no consequence.
>>male #3: So, thanks for the talk. There
were a couple of things that I reacted against
during the talk, which I'm sure happens a
lot. For example, your comparison with a garden,
I don't really find very convincing because
a garden is something that you're nurturing;
it's something that's an old idea of something
which you are nurturing into a different state
whereas this kind of climate engineering is
something where you're trying to patch something
which is going wrong. I'd also put into question
what you said about this is a way of addressing
public apathy because I see it the other way.
If, and this is if people believe already
that we will have technology which will fix
the problems which technology has brought,
and that's, I think, a way of increasing public
apathy rather than decreasing it. But I'm
sure that these are common themes; I don't
want to go into them. Actually, the question
that I had was something that you just touched
on very briefly when you showed the model
of the machine which was removing carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere. You haven't really talked
about carbon's frustration and maybe you could
just give us some idea of if this figures
in your book, or how this fits in this plan
at all, because it seems to be a far more
cost effective way of trapping carbon out
at the source. And it's something that people
have talked lots, so maybe you can put that
into the context of what you've been saying.
>>Jeff: Sure. I just wanna say one thing about
the garden thing, which I know is obviously,
I mean, it obvious my daughter growing pumpkins
and manipulating the entire climate are totally
different, but the point I was trying to make
is about pact of partnerships that, working
with nature in an active way and engaging
and not-- cause I think we tend to think of
the climate and the atmosphere and nature,
in the larger sense, as something that's out
there in its own force of its own. And this
idea of an active management of a problem,
of an ecosystem or anything else-- I mean,
there's a lot of that going on right now with
ecosystem restoration and that kind of thing.
>>male: [inaudible]
>>Jeff: Right.
>>Jeff: Right. Right.
>>male: [inaudible]
>>Jeff: Right, right. No, I totally understand.
Carbon sequestration is really important.
It's, as I said, there's two kinds of geoengineering
in the beginning; the sunlight blocking and
carbon sort of sucking part of it. And the
first thing to point out about carbon sequestration
is it doesn't get away; it doesn't have the
benefit of being, of working immediately,
right? I mean, one of these reasons that this
geoengineering of blocking the sunlight is
so much in the forefront of the conversation
is it can, is it happens very fast, right?
So, carbon sequestration certainly lowers
the amount of carbon going into the atmosphere,
but it doesn't really help if you were thinking
about how do we cool things off if we needed
to quickly, that part of it, conversation.
So, carbon sequestration is something I thought
a lot about because that is the central idea
with coal; is what are we gonna do, how are
we gonna keep burning coal? There's a strong
argument to be made that developing nations--well,
they're obviously going to continue burning
coal-- but they should that there's a economic
and public health benefit to bringing more
and more people into the modern world giving
them more and more services that cheap electricity
give them. And so, there's a lot of money
right now going into how do you capture the
carbon dioxide out of a coal plant and out
of the smokestacks? Essentially, the smokestack
of a coal plant and there are various, a whole
bunch of different ideas about this and, but
the striking thing about that is that none
of it is really happening. I've been watching
the coal industry now, very closely, for ten
years and it's one of these things that the
industry loves to talk about, but doesn't
really wanna do because we'll raise the price
of electricity. And just for those of you
who don't know carbon sequestration is, I
should make it very clear. It's capturing
the CO2 gases out of the smokestack of a coal
plant, most of the time. You can do it on
other types of things, but capturing CO2,
compressing into a super critical liquid and
then pumping it underground into deep storage,
usually in saline aquifers that are way down
several thousand feet below surface. And presumably,
if you do it in the right place, and these
aquifers are in stable geologic systems that
we understand well, it will be locked up down
there for a long time, you'll reduce-- so
you could use the possibility of a essentially
carbon free coal, right, if you could do this.
The problem, though, the problems are many.
One is its, increases the cost of coal-fired
power by half or so. It doesn't work everywhere.
It has to have the right geology in the ground
to do this and most coal plants were not built
with the idea that we need to store carbon,
so they're not built geologically in the right
place. So, you have to pipe the stuff, which
is again, all the headaches of piping and
all that kind of thing and cost of that. And
you have an entrenched industry that basically
sees this as a way of simply increasing their
cost and doesn't wanna do it. And culturally,
they are not very interested in this and they've
done everything they can politically to fight
any kind of regulations that would force them
to do this or they'll actually put a cap.
I mean, one of the reasons we don't have a
cap on carbon, one of the reasons Obama cannot
get anything done on this is because of the
coal industry. Those are the, then the Democrats
in the coal states, who are against any kind
of real cap because it will mean having to
put basically, carbon sequestration on coal
plants which will raise the price, which will
make people go to natural gas and make them,
make renewable energy more affordable and
all the things the coal industry doesn't want.
So, one of the virtues of that air capture
thing that I showed the picture that David
Keith is working on, it's much more expensive
than doing it from a coal plant, but it has
the virtue of, there's a lot of, there can
be a lot of progress that can be made. It's
just a lot of headroom in development of this
technology. It doesn't fight an entrenched
industry; it's separate. It's a thing that
is built on its own. It's doesn't, you don't
have to have; the coal guys are not necessarily
going to be fighting against this. It can
be put in places where the sequestration is
good. We, all you have to do, it doesn't matter
where it is cause when you take a molecule
of CO2 out of the air and the planet, it doesn't
matter where you take it out; it's not like
local air pollution. So, there's many virtues
of this and it's, if you wanna really think
about how we're gonna have low carbon jet
fuel, or air travel, this is one way that
this could happen because it's very difficult
to think about how we're to be flying airplanes
on biofuels and things like that. And the
idea of having a kind of carbon neutral jet
fuel, this is one possibility of that. You
could use it just to offset airline travel;
things like that. So, it's not simple, it's
not easy, but it is a technology that's really
being explored.
Yeah.
>>male #3: So, a little bit related to that,
I wondered if you've looked at all into one
of more far out ideas that I've heard, which
is Freeman Dyson's of bioengineering the Northern
pine forests to sequester more carbon?
>>Jeff: Yeah, well Freeman is so, I have,
he has a number of ideas and I wanna be clear
about which one you're talking about. When
you say bioengineering the pine forests, which
of his ideas do you mean?
>>male #3: He observed that there's a natural
cycle of how much carbon dioxide there is
in the atmosphere, which goes by winter and
summer and he's saying it's because the Northern
pines absorb so much more carbon during the
summer when they're growing. So, he's suggesting
planting a new kind of pine, which accelerates
that enormously and thus, having a big effect
on the amount of carbon dioxide.
>>Jeff: Yeah. And he and others have also
talked about genetically engineering plants
to have wider leaves, so that they could reflect
more sunlight and also have an effect on the
albedo. I mean, I think all of these ideas
are in the mix. I don't see that kind of thing
as happening, having a real possibility of
happening very soon. Partly because I think
the CO2 modulation stuff is gonna be big bang
for the buck, to be really interested for
people right now, and it's this albedo management
stuff that is the real dangerous and interesting
part of this. But I think that, when I was
researching this, there's many--this idea
of geoengineering--there's many ideas out
there that I just, I mean, I can talk to one,
I guess scientist might be too generous of
a word, but a researcher who wanted to change
the albedo of the ocean by dumping Special
K breakfast cereal into the Arctic Sea. Another
who thought that putting, setting off, shooting
a nuclear weapon at the moon to cause moon
dust to go into space and reflect sunlight
away. I mean, there's all kinds, I mean, Plexiglas
on the ocean to reflect sunlight around the
Greenland ice sheets, people with Styrofoam
balls. I mean, people have all kinds of ideas
up, and there's also other issues that I,
I mean, other possibilities that I haven't
even talked about, like dumping iron in the
ocean, which is something that was actually
done for, by some entrepreneurs here in the
Bay area, changing the upwelling currents
to have more of a deep water upwelling and
stimulate plankton blooms that way. It's a
brand new field. There's bazillions of interesting
and mostly crazy ideas out there that people
are exploring and that's fascinating. I mean,
I mentioned of growing up in the Silicon Valley
and it reminds me at a very strange way of
the early days of the PC revolution, where
you had just a lot of crazy ideas and nobody
knows what's gonna work and what's not, but
there's a lot of new thinking going on in
this world and that's, I think, an example.
I mean, Freeman Dyson is a genius, but I have
some question about some of his ideas about
this stuff.
>>Cliff: Well, that's all the time we have
for questions today, so thank you very much,
Jeff. It was an amazing talk.
>>Jeff: Thanks very much.
[applause]